immediately after my college i was
trying to do sales i'm not a sales as
you can tell i'm an engineer by trade um
but i realized that if you send a
personalized video to someone um
they are way more likely to reply to you
uh it just it's uncanny they see that
you're a real human being and you're
just trying to like get their attention
and just want to reach out to them as
opposed to a bot that's sending
thousands of emails at once
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about video editing and
not just video editing but how do we
leverage new technology to make content
creation easier meet kanad bahalkar
kanat is the chief product officer and
co-founder of potion kanat is an
ex-googler and was an early employee at
knit health a camera that could detect
sleeping and breathing disorders using
ai looking forward to having people
listen to our conversation now you know
really getting at the question of why do
you do what you do and you've
done quite a few awesome things the most
recently you user experience researcher
at google and so user experience is a is
a pretty big significant passion of mine
and um
one of the things that you're doing now
is looking at video as a means of
interaction and sales and how to
leverage technology to create it more
personalized and dynamic
while taking less resources from the
creator itself so tell me a little bit
about the space that you're in and how
you've come to think about this problem
sure thing there's a little bit of a
correction that's i used to be a user
research
like user
experience engineer not a researcher i'm
not a smart uh to be a ux researcher
so i was just a liaison between there by
the way so
uxcs or ux engineers are uh
they're actually engineers who
understand the language of user
experience so they are the liaison
between the user experience team and the
engineering team so quickly creating
prototypes testing them to see if they
have validity in the uh in the people
that you're reaching out to
do people like your stuff and so before
you build a a big thing we quickly built
uh smaller things to test if they are
actually a valid business idea or a
valid product
so okay so it's interesting so it's sort
of this you get the best of both worlds
you both get the engineering perspective
but also the user experience
fun of it so so thank you for that that
clarification
the world of video and content and
personalization what's happening there
uh sure thing so uh let me
turn the
wheel of time a little bit back and tell
you why i uh started this
before uh this startup i was working at
uh google and before that i was working
at a small server called knit health and
uh
this is very small team and we built
really cool things um we built our team
built a camera that could uh detect
sleeping and breathing disorders in kids
who have those disorders uh and um
i had seen
our work actually change uh like
sleeping and reading patterns of kids
who were suffering with those things
at that time i got exposed to computer
vision and
how ai can actually help
people with video and
dfix was an up-and-coming field and it
was very nascent very in his infancy
and i wanted to understand these tools
like what is the dynamic there what can
we do
uh to actually make this cool make this
safe
as the defects of technologies is potent
but it's also very dangerous so what can
we do to actually uh build cool things
using this technology while at the same
time i'm making it safe and secure so
that's where the germination of the idea
came from and uh played around with it a
little bit experienced exp experimented
with it a little bit and um
i met my co-founder during that time and
uh we decided to build a company
i love it and so
looking more concretely at the
opportunity that you have in video and
and the intersection of sales what is
the sort of the aha moment that you had
or how did you even get to that specific
product that you're building today with
creating these personalized videos you
know a great question so before a
project uh way back
in uh immediately after my college i was
trying to do sales i'm not a sales as i
can tell i'm an engineer by trade um
but i realized that if you send a
personalized video to someone um
they are way more likely to reply to you
uh it's just it's uncanny they they see
that you're a real human being and
you're just trying to like get their
attention and just want to reach out to
them as opposed to a bot that's sending
thousands of emails at once and so
literally you're sending a video as a
cold outreach so instead of just
text explaining everything you're
sending them a personalized video where
you're actually talking to them and this
is
a replacement for the cold email pretty
much yes it's it's actually an
enhancement to the cold email so usually
i still use text but in that we also
embed a video uh to explain either in
detail or just add a personal flair uh
to to the text so
uh if you do that it's way more likely
for people to engage with you but it's
impossible to scale you're not going to
go hey michael this is canard hey johnny
this is kind of hundreds of times for
all the people that you want to reach
out to so that was a problem and
the technology that was up and coming
was a potential solution so we tried to
experiment with those and that turns out
sales people want to do it
uh so we just decided to build a company
how do you sort of mitigate the
so you have this user experience inside
right where you're saying if we're able
to make it to make the the listener feel
that they're more engaged because this
is more targeted to them more
personalized and they're more likely to
to engage with the content
are so
i'm assuming there will be an inflection
point where people sort of realize this
right where potion is going to become
significant enough that you know every
sales videos will be made through
through this
how do you perceive people the consumer
behavior shifting at that point will
people still find it engaging and
personalized well they will they you
know feel a little detached because they
realize that it's a software doing it
how do you think through sort of the
trajectory of this technology
great question
so uh this is a new form of
communication right um and for every new
form of communication there is a curve
of excitement and then it dies on once
people catch up to
and that's not just with personalized
videos or any other personalized things
it's just the nature of the game uh so
if you look at email as a means of
communication when it came out you used
to get like 80 90 open rates but now it
has died down a lot because people are
more desensitized to that sure which is
true with every single means of
communication so we do expect that to
happen but it's a good problem to have
it's not necessarily a bad thing it's
just that if
something is overdone people get
desensitized to that that's just human
nature so we're not necessarily worried
about it we expect expected we
anticipated
right and so what what and then
is that changing in any way you know the
the way that you're building your
product to your team your your vision
for this company the sort of this
desensitizing idea
a great question so uh we actually have
a significantly wider vision than what
we're building now so right now we allow
sales people to
change a few words in a video uh using
our technology which is cool is really
useful for sales teams
but the same technology can be used to
do many many things such as changing
an entire video from english to german
or any other language just by changing
the subtitles
or lip syncing tv or uh movies uh or
even uh creating a personalized employee
onboarding content the possibilities of
the same
technology being applied in different
contexts is significantly large so what
are we going to do about it uh
so
we are next year we're trying to release
an api that allows developers to build
their own applications on top of our app
so right now we're starting with a very
small specific use case then we're going
to expand to a video editor that allows
people to edit videos just by editing
text and it's not just removing words
it's also like adding stuff from adding
content to the video late next year once
we democratize uh this technology with
any with an api developers can actually
leverage it for their own applications
so i'm hearing three different three
different verticals that are coming
together here first you have this the
idea of sales and and marketing and
personalization right then you have this
vertical of uh of the content creation
right you're talking about creators and
how do we create content or create
anything that is engaging and
entertaining and then you have this
vertical of developers as an engineer
yourself
you're thinking okay how do i now
empower a whole marketplace or a whole
whole world of development through this
foundation that i'm building in the
market here
which which of these
do you personally most relate to where
where is canada in sort of the in this
whole spectrum that i've tried outlining
here at the end game i really want to
democratize this technology make it as
safe and secure
as possible uh and
just see what people do with it uh i
have no idea what cool ideas will people
implement using this but uh that's what
i'm really excited about
we understand that we've chosen a very
narrow problem to solve right now but
that's because the company is nascent we
don't have the ai is not sophisticated
enough to produce robust results all the
time as we collect more user data we can
actually get better and better over time
but the end game is what i'm really
really excited about
interesting and so you're talking about
you're basically saying i as an
entrepreneur i'm setting the foundation
and and what i really care about is to
see how the world responds and how
everybody is interacting with this
technology and building on top of it
right yes sir so give me some examples
if you had to now you know if we had a
20 engineers that are ready to to use
this api and to build you know really
cool apps uh on their own with potions
technology what what what types of
things would you empower them to to try
and do
absolutely so uh
i came up with a bunch of ideas right
now just like off the top of my head but
uh since i'm working like sales and
marketing people like those are the top
of mind ideas for me so creating hyper
personalized ads on
instagram or facebook is like an easy
solution or uh if you make a youtube
video as a creator um
and you realize that you made a mistake
uh where you want like you want to
change the sentence in that entire video
uh do something else you don't want to
remove it you want to just change the
context of it how do you do that you
have to record the whole thing right
with us you don't have so you just
change the text in the subtitles or the
transcription and it automatically
creates accurate lip sync for you
or as an employee you join
apple and tim cook comes on your screen
personally welcomes you and actually
walks you through uh the employee
onboarding journey yeah there's the
possibilities of these are literally
listen entertainment gaming uh
as as long as you have accurate lip sync
and accurate uh voice cloning uh you can
apply that in many many contexts
sure tell me a little bit about the
strategy for winning here so you're
talking about the end game and you're
not just building a product you're
building a a foundation and an
infrastructure for others and this is
technology that you know that we that
we're seeing emerge and and and you know
we have a variety of different
organizations that are looking at these
technologies in different lenses
what is your approach with potion for
winning in this in this long game why is
potion going to succeed here
that's a great question uh honestly this
is a very uh um
i'm gonna be extra honest here uh i'm
not talking to you because you're uh
you're bc i'm talking to you as like oh
preach like friends uh kind of situation
so i don't want just us to succeed i'm
pretty sure there are other companies
who are gonna solve this problem in a
different lens as well what we want to
do is we want to build a platform that
allows people to create these pieces of
content securely and we also want to
build a community of developers that
support each other to actually uh will
build anything on top of version so
that's what we believe in the long term
would succeed so we have started taking
steps towards what can we do to add to
the security layer what can we do to
create this as a platform plug and play
into other video editing tools building
a community so those are the things that
we believe will make us win but honestly
i'm pretty sure there's going to be
other companies that will take a stab at
the problem as well and uh we hope to
collaborate with them as well so it
sounds like you're really doubling down
on the community aspect on the first you
know having people trust could create
trust in the infrastructure that you're
building with that sort of the security
lens that you were saying before but
then also the community aspect of how do
we empower developers to work with each
other work with content creators and
figure out different ways to leverage to
leverage the software at that point how
do you envision potion being a part of
this part of this player is it sort of a
licensing mechanism that that you are
the core technology that uh that other
apps are using and is it still the
potion brand that that the end consumers
are getting exposed to or that the
developers are getting exposed to in
other words where are you in the in the
mindset of your consumers as as you
scale up potion to be a developer play
for many people to use and build apps on
a great question so
we look at ourselves as uh aws for
synthetic media
and that's just uh
that's just a platform that allows
developers to do things that they want
to do it's a conglomeration of multiple
products although we're starting with
one product right now slowly we'll
release trust-based and security-based
products that
inspires confidence in developers that
their technology is not going to be
misused and then we'll also double down
on the community aspect of it so portion
as a brand probably will not be exposed
to the end consumer as heavily just like
when you go on a website if served by
aws the consumer doesn't see that served
by aws it is interacting with a product
or a service so that's where we want to
be there are a bunch of things that we
need to build to make this more secure
um
i'll give you a couple examples right
now so uh as a policy we don't allow
people to create defect videos of
anybody else but themselves
that's like one of the core tenants of
our
company policy so uh i had to fire a
customer last week because they misused
uh this technology they basically
misused our tech uh they gave someone
their password and somehow they figured
how to use someone else's face uh well
his boss space in in the in the video
wow so we had to fire them uh which is
not an easy thing to do for a small
startup but uh
uh so those are the types of things like
voice fingerprinting face fingerprinting
those are the types of security things
we we're gonna build and broker that as
a platform to developers so uh they
don't have to worry about
anything from a security or malicious
intent perspective
how is that
security and and trust building play
into
you know your strategy for winning here
because they i first of all i think it's
it's it's admirable and it's amazing
that i i'm very i'm very happy to hear
that you're putting so much effort into
this yet i can't help but understand it
it's a little bit contradictory to
to scaling quickly to getting you know
because it you know you're you're
effectively regulating your customers
you're regulating the use of your
product which is naturally limiting the
usage of the product and so yes first of
all why why is this such a
cornerstone or foundational idea that as
you're building potion ah this
this is actually an important question
to discuss
um
if you remember a few years ago there
was an obama deep fake um done by i
think one of the key and peel one of the
comedians out there and
that's where
i'd started
thinking about okay what can be done to
actually use the same technology in in a
good way as opposed to a bad way
so that's where the germination of the
idea came from
it's really easy to misuse this
technology for political gains or to
create mistrust among people or just
disseminate bad content
with malicious intent
we would rather have less customers
than not
if uh
if people are using our technology for
nefarious reasons i don't want to be a
part of it
so i want to make sure as a founder of
the company that i build the right
frameworks and policies in the company
that allow us to do that in the long run
and
do how do you find that your
teammates investors board members or i
mean is everybody sort of aligned on
this on this mission everybody has this
same conviction or is this something
that you have to tell me and and the
second question there's a follow-up to
this is what about your employees i mean
how do you get your employees and your
team members as you're building your
team to have this as a
really foundational piece of who they
are
yes um
our head of day i'm marcus and my
co-founder andrew
all of us are aligned on this uh
particular thing like we just don't want
this technology to be used for bad
reasons it's a reasonable thing to do
and we every single time we pitch to our
investors before they became investors
we made sure that
this is this point is communicated to
them so if they come in with a different
expectation uh that that doesn't align
with us we may not have a deal here so
this was communicated through and
through before and after uh we got
investments as well as new employees as
well so yes the team is aligned and we
communicate frequently that okay this is
uh what we're gonna do this is what
we're gonna stick with
and is this mainly a
sort of a a verbal or
sort of a cultural idea or is this also
technologically something that you're
spending time and effort to to develop
because i imagine there are different
opportunities that could be done
technologically to to to increase
authentication like you mentioned
fingerprinting before
yeah so both uh culturally we are
inclined uh
towards that direction
hence we build the solutions in such a
way that the technology also complies
with
with what we think and feel
so
examples of being voice fingerprinting
or having stronger contracts for
actually using the technology in a
specific way uh those types of things
are uh what we're building towards uh to
like build that layer of trust
fantastic well it sounds like you're
working on some some really phenomenal
ideas and some really phenomenal
products and i can only imagine what
what the world can do with with more
personalized video content and i think
that you're you're you're right on the
point of of understanding the dangers of
it and the pitfalls and one and you're
mentioning that you know by
democratizing sort of this ability
you're also democratizing the ability to
from misuse and this is true really for
any product but here specifically it has
more of a of a human nature and so i i
really respect your
sort of your motivation for being so
intentional with with the way that
you're running this and and i can't wait
to use the product myself and i really
cannot thank you so much for coming here
and for taking this time and how busy
you are for sharing your story with me
and then i look forward to following
your journey so thank you
thank you so much michael uh this was
super fun and uh feel good reach out to
me anytime
[Music]